welcome to this video yeah
yesterday I played a thirty minute game
on a 15 minute game 30 minutes in total
playing time on the I associate I've
gotten I've gotten a modern Benoni
fianchetto variation which reminded me
of a classic game played them between
Viktor Korchnoi and Garry Kasparov and
this is a really memorable game that I
felt that is worth sharing again on them
on the channel not again I didn't do it
before but it's it's simply a great
battle very complicated game and just
just a few words to describe them
circumstances of this game because this
is very important to understand the
relevance just between the pure moves I
mean the pure moves are fantastic but
the whole scenario was just very
remarkable this game has been played in
November 1982
so already more than 30 years ago in
1982 Kasparov was 19 years old not yet a
world champion but he was clearly
destined to become the Challenger for
Karpov who at the time had been world
champion for seven years and was clearly
dominating the field Fischer retired and
didn't defend the title in 75 and
cap-off became world champion but after
that basically won everything that was
possible so it was a very dominating
world champion but because far off it
was clear that he is by far the most
promising future Challenger and 1982
here we had the the chess olympiad
played in Lucerne Switzerland so this
was played on Korchnoi his home ground
he of course had left the Soviet Union
in the in the 70s and was considered to
be a let's say in are outlawed by the
Soviet authorities so he really was
something like public enemy
one and should be defeated he had
challenged come up of two times for the
world title and 78-81 lost both times
and now in 82 he still was probably if
you discount Kasparov from the the main
rival for Karpov probably brought number
two at the time I'm not quite sure I
didn't look up the word rankings but
it's it's close to that Kasparov was
lower rated because he was simply so new
on the scene and okay this is the Chess
Olympiad so a team event bought one for
the Soviet Union at the time was Karpov
and Kasparov already played on board two
and the question was am who will play
against Switzerland the cap off simply
didn't didn't want to play and took a
yeah it took a timeout so to say and it
was widely regarded that the strategy
behind that was to let us borrow from
play against Korchnoi with black and
maybe yeah let coercion or teach him a
lesson so it was regarded that Karpov
tried to yeah somewhat damaged his
future challenger by just taking this
time out
so Kasparov needed to play bought one in
a very important encounter and let's see
what happened we start with one deform
caution I always preferred the close
game c4 and d4 his main moves for for
his whole career which is so remarkably
long he yeah he still was active just
like two years ago nowadays his health
does not permit any air chess anymore
this is turning 83 or 84 this year okay
Kasparov are playing Knight f6 g6
clearly signaling the aggressive
intentions not going for Queen's Gambit
or any conservative defense and he still
he played the Kings Indian back
back then Kasparov and caution applied
g3 which is some slightly surprising not
it's not like he didn't play this before
he did but got annoyed nowadays mostly
known for his very aggressive approach
in the classical kings in Yin there's
even a line that is usually entitled the
caution or variation and this is this is
this line with night e1 and Bishop e3 in
fact this has been discussed between
karna antics power of later with the
conspire of usually having the better of
it he was simply a fantastic Kim C
King's Indian player but here g3 was
played Bishop g7 and Bishop g2 and now
it was part of plays c5 which is an
interesting choice he and at the time
did not want to go into typical Kings
Indian structures in his later career he
also had played of course the goon
thought with d5 Layton is played this
line the classical line with this since
later he five but he s c5 was played now
d5 going for a benoni structure the
white also has Knight f3 which allows
them some interesting lines maybe when
I'm mentioning is Queen a5 check which
is a pretty decent line for black if you
want an offbeat weapon against the
fianchetto the screen a5 can be can be
handy there's also this interesting
variation that can lead to tricky play
ok back then caution of play d5 d6 play
/ Kasparov it's important to note that
the early g3 here prevented any not that
one he prevented any adventure were like
ambitions because of d6 advise just wins
the game instantly you need to play d6
um and now after Knight c3
b5 ambition is simply prevented castle
sinaia 396 so black does not want to
play a standard Benoni on with a ancient
form of Bologna but go to the modern Ben
Oni this makes sense much more active
this way because black has got the ephod
to play on played a6 very standard move
and a4 of course to prevent b5 now rook
e8 was played yeah and this position is
so discussed nowadays of course the
fianchetto is relatively popular
nowadays against the benoni simply
because it quite often arises from an
entirely different move order namely
here if I can point that out just
quickly if black plays ecigs and then g3
for the Catalan black quite often reply
c5 which after this can lead to the game
position easily you can see it unfolding
this is in fact where modern be known is
nowadays mostly arise from with g3 from
the Catalonian
order okay rook e8 plate and here corner
plate 92 which is the traditional
mainline and also still played nowadays
the more modern moves but back then it
wasn't popular this Bishop f4 here this
is interesting because it immediately
attacks the d6 pawn so black cannot
easily just develop the bishop because
it hangs on d6 um black can't play
Knight e4 however a move that Knight d2
is designed to prevent but 94 is not
term that terrible this is White's reply
and like now must be aware that 94 is
coming quickly must do something against
it so black plays the funky food look at
before and yeah here we have a very
interesting and sharp position
we're White has many possibilities in
fact that was interesting to discover
that this has been played between Levon
Aronian and magnus carlsen back in
nineteen not 19 2007 when they play down
a candidate's match for the World
Championship Challenger because of
course a thousand back then was only am
I think it was 16 yeah if you consider
the month when it was played so Aronian
i won that game later b 3 was played
then offering an exchange so the Benoni
is full of those dynamic technical
possibilities and hacked cards not
played played interesting he just gave
the exchange up and then took on a 1 and
this led to a position where it's
probably between equal and whites being
slightly better white is somewhat better
developed and there are still weaknesses
in blacks camp but it's nothing too
serious
very often a black nowadays does not
play 94 even for instance just about one
month ago in zurich unicameral played
aged 6 cm against them against Caruana
an interesting move that covers the g5
square and koala played quincy one king
aged seven rupee one preparing e-form so
on still a topical line but the caution
of plate 92 back then this was
considered to be the absolute main line
97 and h3 yeah this is universally
regarded as a useful move it covers the
important g4 square the thing is if you
look at the night on d7 where's it going
to go
the five is the most likely spot where
it will move and if like play this now
you have prepared a form so g4 has
covered but I cannot go here anymore so
he would just need to return back to
these seven sir this does not make much
sense it's a good prophylactic move
Black is playing rugby aid which is just
stronger it turn threatens to play b5
and this is something that white
absolutely needs to react to if black is
going to play b5 he will have a good
game instantly so white is playing
Knight c4 to attack the pawn and just he
needs to speed up the play here and make
sure to prevent b5 with the same direct
play yeah now black has two moves at his
disposal he's got a very sharp knife and
the more conservative move the
conservative movie is night to b6 this
is trying to exchange the strong c4
Knight which Y does not want to do
really this this kind of thing is quite
comfortable for black in general in the
Benoni in the modern benoni if black
manages to exchange like let's say two
pairs of minor pieces let's say the c8
bishop and the d7 light this usually
leads to a very decent position for
black he has slightly cramped and if he
manages to exchange one or two pieces
this would help him enormously simply
because you have less space available
for your pieces so having lesser pieces
or having yeah not so many pieces is
just helpful while white having the
space advantage does not want to
exchange this also shows by after Knight
b6 white is school usually playing
Knight a3 it looks a bit strange to put
it on the edge of the board but white is
intending to play a 5 and then return it
to c4 and now black plays Bishop d7 an
interesting idea the idea is that after
a 5 black is going back to c8 again
looking strange but there is a good
square actually on b5 coming up so this
is an interesting alternative because
Sparrow fire ever wanted to have a an
even more confrontational that's how I
played 95 putting it in the center
and here's the same scenario why does
not really want to exchange him as
exchanges generally favor black
therefore night a3 was played and this
intends to push the night back and then
return and similar to the other scenario
where I'm a five was the move that
pushed the night back on a three we also
have an additional controller over B
five so this is not easily played young
and here because power off played the
night to age five the thing is with this
maneuver 9075 black IAM yeah let's say
he's already committed to very direct
play you cannot play any any slow moves
anymore simply because if you allow the
the night from if five being pushed back
with a four without any severe
punishment on put upon white then white
simply has won the opening battle and
night age five is the first move that
technically establishes this night only
five what happens if white plays f4 here
the most natural looking at taking the
night yeah in fact this is a really
risky because black can capture on g3
and sacrifice a piece on if i if this
night is sacrificed and tea black simply
recaptures this is leading to a very
dangerous attack the rook here is
immediately attacked and if it if it
tries to to save from save itself let's
say going to f3 then black is playing
Queen h4 and that is Bishop takes h3
coming up black is attacking with many
many pieces and those pieces here are
not defending at all this one included
so this is already a very dangerous the
computer is even not giving it as a
direct win for black so very dangerous
play with f4 that wide rarely rarely
risks relief it's not it's not great
simply the other move that is very
direct is of course is g4 now I can also
try to attack the h5 night and trying to
push it back that way and then maybe go
f4 at the right moment but again like
has a tactical way to play in this
position black can play Queen h4 again
offering a piece sacrifice if you take
this again is exceptionally great for
black you have this coming up with the
potential made on h2 and again this is
already an a winning winning position
there are many funny lines here if you
look at this for example and now going
for this square to cover black has this
great Czech resource intending rook
takes h5 and this is flat-out winning
for black it's a very very funny line
that's no way to do two for y to save
the king if you take bishop takes this
is again threatening a checkmate and
this check check check check mate you're
so well known mating pattern so this is
very risky moving anything in front of
the king and caution oil wisely avoided
that um he played the movie for which is
even nowadays the the main move here
just securing a foothold in the center
and now power of played rook f8 which
looks a bit strange but it supports the
f5 break this is what blacks planets he
needs to justify this Knight e5 Knight
h5 with direct plane instead of rogue f8
other moves nowadays it is regarded that
black should play Bishop d7 and prepare
b5 the idea is that F for now is
answered by b5 which leads to
exceptionally complicated play which is
believed to be quite good for black f4
is probably not the best move white
normally plays a5
the idea is tactical to have discovered
discovered attacks on the Queen if it
captures and black normally goes for b5
him takes and Bishop b5 this is played
even in a game and one from 2013 between
put a my event to back row leading to
leading to unclear play when Black has
sacrificed the pawn for great pressure
on the bee farm yeah just to show that
this is still a modern a modern opening
look f8 was played as mentioned to get
f5 in and now caution I played King edge
to a good prophylactic move that covers
the g3 pawn to support an F form if we
look at G for this is again the
possibility like is going Queen h4 again
this this was known back then from a
game between Sheeran and young team on
Tim on back then being the best player
of the Western world together with the
German Robert Huth now G takes h5 bishop
h3 and black again had an exceptionally
strong attack something that what really
does not want to play especially
considering that that Kasparov is
sitting on the other side of the board
back then it was already clear that he
was the absolute an absolutely brilliant
dynamic player so it was really advised
to not go into such a sharp battle
and its really a typical for caution or
that he does not shy away from from a
sharp metal it's already clear that this
will need to do to something
exceptionally complicated because the
gap coming f4 needs to be justified
tactically by black and we see how this
is going to unfold yeah here Kasparov
played the move f5 and this is um it
seems from a modern perspective a
mistake the thing is that white now can
can play a four we see it in the game
and this is hard to justify so what
should black play the alternative to f5
nowadays is considered to be again
Bishop to d7 the idea is again a 4 B 5
technically justifying this this whole
procedure right now normally place
something like Queen e2 covering b5
again and only then and 5 this is for
instant played in a game just a couple
of years ago between Victor last niche
gun and a player called Kononenko also
Grand Master I only have the initial I
think it's Dmitriy record show and this
after F 4 F takes e4 Fe 593 led to here
hair-raising complications which rather
similar to the game we would see that
something like that happens in the main
game as well ok this is how it is played
nowadays f5 it seems it's not not that
great but we see in the game that this
is not something that is
easily or that it can easily be proven
it's just act exceptionally complicated
yeah coach Choi is not shying away from
the battle of course he plays f4
attacking this night and what brought
this position the night is attacked and
turn if black now just retreats it yeah
place a somewhat pedestrian move like
that
for example then white is simply better
because of the capture note that the
night on h5 is hanging you cannot
recapture here it's just gone and the
Bishop f5 yeah there is the smooth I'm
not sure you should play it immediately
but this is just winning a piece there's
maybe Queen h4 again but it's probably
not as dangerous as before there are
ideas like that for example black
absolutely does not want to retreat the
night he wants to play in a way that
this is working as a sacrifice and
what's provost doing is remarkable he's
playing b5 regardless of this hanging
night he just wants to have the absolute
maximum activity for his position and
yeah here coach no I captures on b5 yeah
what happens if he takes the night we
need to examine that of course F takes
e5 it's a a very risky move because of
night g3 again this piece sacrifice yeah
white probably needs to take it cannot
tolerate Bishop takes e5 happening and
so takes check and now you need to go to
l2 it's obviously a very Airy King
position and here black probably should
go before and establish this double
attack you get one piece back black hand
sacrificed
pleases here but you get one back and
still retain a dangerous attack know
what that here white cannot get the
strong bishop because he takes between
this is a important line
he must recapture and then after yeah
this an Bishop before coming Black has
some number of pawns I think three
points two points but still a very
strong attack if you gives us to the
computer for a while that always
assesses this as zero zero zero
probably repetitions and perpetual check
sir
coming up it's very dangerous for why
it's in a practical game you you don't
really want to do that oh gosh no it
took on b5 after some thought and just
after that took on b5 which is a very
young understandable practical decision
it's simply this night whenever black
retreats it White has basically won the
opening battle and he also he is already
upon up you shouldn't forget that and
white needs to to judge correctly when
to take the night you can really expect
black never to retreat it something like
that it's just terrible
I mean white also but besides that which
is very strong he also has coups ideas
like that so it's quite funny black is
never going to retreat he wants to play
for maximum activity he took on e4 which
is the best move in the position and
again we need to consider what happens
if white takes and again it's not so
great if white takes black has two
interesting tries Bishop e5
simply recapturing 190 393 is an
interesting moves as well it's um check
this is happening
but now there is a six and this is the
main problems its this cuts the bishop
away and after move like Bishop to e5
white can go here and there is no
decisive attack coming up black Hill
does not have this square because of the
night and it's too much sacrificing on
g3 but black can simply recapture and
this is leading to a strong attack
y-term should probably change one pair
of rooks and then it's basically
impossible to defend the square black
Willam at this pawn black will capture a
possible line 9f Queen everyone and now
let's say this is 93 kg 1 and Bishop and
5 and tell me here black has a very very
decent compensation for the piece he's
got 2 points and a very active pieces
with a with the weak White King and
somewhat somewhat questionable
coordination by white and a practical
game this is certainly a good way to
play for black you can argue that maybe
why this is better if you give it to a
computer but it's very very tricky to
play I don't think really F takes d5 is
a good practical choice there was an
alternative though coach Noah took on e4
and as mentioned before there was an
alternative 96 giving up the knight
first and then capture this is in fact
interesting as Queen d6 is not really
great because of 94 that was the idea
you get to eat for with temple and
capture only 5 after that so that after
here the knight is defending g3 this in
fact leads to a very good position for
white with this move intending it is
cover check and attacking
see five yeah g3 nicely protected now
with the night this is an interesting
line but after night takes D six black
it's not force to recapture he has an
has an alternative and okay it's this
funny move again everything's hanging
here all night signing yeah
and this is again leading to an
interesting play if white now captures
here black can take here with check
check and then win-win material even he
needs to take the night and then Queen D
694 and Queen b6 and this is different
now as right now cannot really take if
you look at this check the King has no
good square I mean h4 s simply it's
simply too insane you won't survive that
so black cam keeps the knight on e5 and
has good play against this murky King
there should be three in this probably
what would white should do attacking c5
and it's it's a completely unclear
position which you could analyze for
ages an interesting way to play the over
white but caution s movers is good and
and strong we should be for yeah
Kasparov now with Bishop d7 counter
checking on b5 which white needs to
address he just played Queen e2 which is
good what else was there why term could
capture only six but this is answered by
the strong reply Queen f6 another night
it does not have any square funny
everything's covered sea floor covered
b5 covered and of course you cannot take
here because f1 is hanging even that is
good
play on g3 white had an alternative
though I'm a very computer issues nine a
seven this was interesting it was
dismissed I guess because of Rukh ahead
but wise hands okay - this is a really a
typical computer line that is almost
impossible for a human player to to even
think of putting the night here on the
edge of the board the idea is that you
get the c6 square of course and it it's
based on the fact that at some point
black needs to do something about the
night white will probably improve the
position somewhat and triad threatened
to take it at some point it's it's an
interesting way to play but very unhuman
cautious move was just good he played as
mentioned twenty-two over protecting b5
lending support to e4 and getting the
Queen into the game just the good news
Queen b6 this make sense what else black
needs to establish this counter tag
again and now Knight a3 was played now
Knight a seven root K eight is not
leading to much so back to a three and
again what is black about to to with
this Knight pure retreat it just to show
it again white will get to c4 with the
tempo and just enjoy an extra pawn with
no problems at all you simply cannot do
that you must play it with the P
sacrifice and Kasparov just went rogue B
to e8 going for the open file here and
again we need to examine the temperature
if white captures now black cam can
simply recapture as now the g3 pawn is
almost impossible to defend
yeah if in fact it
impossible to defend it's probably
something like that going to happen
check and black has some very strong
compensation for the piece note that
after Queen d8 the queen is quickly
coming into the play and h3 is going to
be lost as well this again wasn't great
he played Bishop b2 it seems that this
was a mistake here in fact white
probably had had a route to him to an
advantage and as I mentioned this f5
move is considered to be dubious and in
fact which is very remarkable but coach
no a plate here this is the sword
sequence of moves it's it's one of the
maybe the strongest possible
continuation only here he could play
better
note that this is almost this is from
1982 they didn't have any computers back
then this wasn't any home prepared
analysis it was just worked out over the
board and commercially had to find his
way around all this complications he
probably had looked at this up to let's
say somewhere around here and everything
after that was worked out over the board
you can also see that when you look at
the the time used okay here it seems
that the best move is Queen to g2 which
is which was even back then right after
the game was was found that this seems
to be a strong move the Queen moves out
of this rook file which makes lots of
sense and also covers the sensitive g3
pawn it's tricky what should black do
now again if you retreat the night you
run into a position where white is just
much better this tempo d6 is weak and
white has upon
not to not to forget the best move
probably is Queen to b3 again try to
play it as a peace sacrifice and now
white again should refrain from taking
it but play even one more prophylactic
move something like rook f2 or the
computer even suggests the strange move
Bishop b1 very strange but rook f2 and
it's getting more and more difficult for
lucky to improve its position in a way
that you don't retreat the night here
it's in fact I think the case that black
has no move anymore
besides Knight f7 and this probably
refutes black Sun up it's still lucky
it's not like white is winning outright
but it's um just very bad very much
better for white but coroner didn't
didn't find this move he played to the
move Bishop d2 and this is serve as
mentioned a mistake because the other
one was just stronger now Kasparov grabs
grabs his chance he took on b2 which at
first sight looks a bit weird because
what about rook F 2 b1 maybe it is
simply that Korchnoi
had mister the reply it's it's it's
possible he didn't play rugby 1 of
course it is a bad move and if you like
you can pause the video and try to work
out why this is not not good for white
I'll be silent for a couple of seconds
yeah black has the tactical stroke night
and recheck and yeah black is winning
out right this is just giving away the
change and twin takes Jack Queen takes
is also winning because c3 is falling
it's always check this is also not
working because of the capture and like
it's winning in the house
this is the technical justification of
Queen takes b2 and yeah I don't know
it's hard to tell maybe Coronel did
overlook that and now had to invent
something else
what should why do he has in fact two
moves available here that are very
interesting to analyze one of them is
Queen g2 again getting out of the e-file
and they are threatening this would be
one idea again black now has a technical
reply again Knight f3 a quite
interesting
Bishop f3 and Bishop takes c3 this is
what black can play after 9 c4 Queen
before the shift C stream and Quincy
form in 22 we have gotten a position
after Knight f6 where white is not any
not in any danger and you can even argue
that maybe he is slightly more
comfortable with the bishops but black
is some not in bad shape
his structures relatively healthy and
he's got active pieces the Knight has an
idea here with the bishop may play on
the square force well this is one thing
that white could have tried there's also
the news might see to getting the knight
out of the fire and intending to use it
only 3 and this was also playable
leading to an exceptionally complicated
play again in fact it's quite
interesting if you look at this position
I analyze it a bit um that black has all
pieces all those pieces on it's on the
optimal squares it's it's hard to
improve them and it's difficult to tell
what what black should do one
possibility is probably to just retreat
the Queen he regained the Palmer V 2 so
it's a
not so dramatic anymore if you need to
retreat the night after all you're not a
pawn down and wide after night see -
it's not immediately threatening to go
to the critical see Foursquare in fact
Queen b7 seems to be quite okay for
black if white now takes we need to
examine it again and again it's again
the case that black has enough firm
enough played no term the funny tactics
iam it's attacked Bishop the force not
working this is saying and how do you
protect it if you protect it like that
black even has the miss Knight f6 which
is very interesting it's using this this
e-file threatening Bishop c3 taking on
e4 and there are positions where white
is so much tied down
even being a piece up that black has
enough compensation it's a very
difficult here to to find a move even
for white that is not losing material
you cannot move that because of the
night and what exactly are you playing
now if you play something like that for
example black is going to capture here
and before it's gone yeah it's a you
need to calculate all this over the
board it's amazing okay what did coach
should I play in fact he played he
played Benz and he couldn't simply
extend it any longer and had captured
the knight on e5 and it turns out that
in this particular case it's not even
leading to an unclear position but it's
leading to a loss position Kasparov of
course simply recaptured a now caution
of late night c4 this was the idea but
black now can react to his to this a
check on the Queen by capturing on g3
and this is the the whole problem it
turns out that instead of Knight takes
g3 black
so could have played rook F 1 this also
was strong the idea being that after
Knight takes b2 you just take on g3 and
you threaten and an amazing an amazing
discovered check of the night and Dwight
simply has says no mafia if you take on
everyone black is capturing this was
check and even this and yeah at the end
he's up to pawns and even will win more
material because why this is completely
in disarray rook f1 was a very strong
move as well but Kasparov took on g3
which was perfectly perfectly all right
and now okay you need to take one
resolve rouga f8 and now Queen e1 yeah
what needed to do that what else the
queen is attacked and taking here is
simply giving up without a fight here we
have a position type that we saw before
black two points up no counter play
whatsoever you can you could as well
resign here so you need to fight and
Canaria is one of the greatest fighters
in chess history he continued with Queen
e1 and of course it looks it looks
terrible
with this discovered check but what
could you do 90s before check and King G
- yeah taking the bishop it's not
helping after 92 because black is
threatening this enormous discovered
check and there is no move here
rook a - you take him to note that this
is hanging as well completely winning
four blankets probably a frost made or a
he played King G - nothing else
and here Kasparov played the live Queen
c2 the queen is attacked after all it
seems that he had to stronger move him
but it wasn't easy to calculate of
course it's a limited time control game
not the correspondence game
something it seems that the rook takes
f2 was strong yeah it's a move that it's
not yeah you consider but you can easily
dismiss because of some details the
point is that after Queen f2 Black has
the good jump
Bishop takes h3 check it's all with
temple so that King takes is winning
very easily in the end black takes the
rook and the point is where some black
going to go a white going to go if you
go on the back rank this is falling with
check and King f3 is uncertain Bishop g4
check very important after this there's
a c2 and check this wins the Queen and
probably will result in a mate as well I
just probably have a checkmate in a
couple of Musa yeah and this is this is
channel 2 a mate so this um this was
winning you'll also need to look at the
Kings here King um h1 for example check
this is winning Johanna very very nice
check checkmate
funny checkmate so it seems that rook F
2 was was winning in a relatively
simpler simple fashion relatively
speaking but it's Kasparov writes in his
in his book that he had seen those lines
but he thought that Queen c2 was even
simpler it's about what he played but in
the process he did overlook something
white now took only fire which is the
best practical decision again um taking
only form is simply not cheating up any
resistance blackest just material up
here so need to do this 95 and
here Kasparov played rock f2 and this
now makes it really tricky if he would
have taken Knight XD - it would have
been still relatively relatively easy
one point being that rook a to check is
answered by Knight f3 check very funny
way with a counter the counter check
here rook see 291 winning back
everything the Queen and the rook and
black is winning he also saw this line
but he overlooked something with rook f2
and this is what he played rook F 2 and
here Korchnoi sacrificed the Queen with
Queen takes f2 white also could have
moved the King as funny as it looks King
g1 and after rook takes D to take on e4
this in fact isn't so easy I mean at
first you might think okay over what the
heck you know isn't black just winning
but it's not it's not so easy if you for
instance check Queen takes c3 white is
getting a dangerous counter-attack and
now this move and very surprisingly this
isn't so clear White has substantial
count to play and it's not it's not
clear if this is really winning check
you can give a couple of checks here
check like that then you need to retreat
at some point and this is not 100% clear
as weird as it looks
White has a CH 495 ideas and this can be
really tricky to play it seems that
black here should take only five and
this seems to lead to win after Queen
takes e5 and then Queen f5 yeah the key
here is is safe on f7
the snoer direct direct check even yeah
it's it's really an enormous leap
difficult position to calculate cotton I
gave up the Queen for counter plane and
this is so very tricky to do to play
Knight takes and now rook a to and this
is what Kasparov had overlooked when he
went for this whole procedure with with
Queen c2 it seems that black is still
winning but it's it's tricky now really
tricky
he played Queen f5 which is a very
strong move plate and time trouble
already
and Bishop h3 is the very obvious choice
but it's not so good really look at this
King g1 and Queen b3 at the Queensland
must go somewhere let's say here and now
a white is coming on the seventh rank
with a check check check again Jeff how
do you how do you win yo it's black you
probably need to advance the King if you
go back like this
check check
checkmate you run into a crazy self meet
you need to advance go here and tell ya
the King it is serve it is a tricky
position for the King white can just
play this move here and play for an
attack black really has a hard time now
to defend this if you retreat the night
for example save that here then 94 King
and 596 check King f6 Bishop g5 Nate is
a mate again it's really really great
black cannot save the knight here
because of those made threats he
probably needs to play move like g5 and
after king f2 this is entirely unclear
it's hard to tell what's happening White
has some attack against the king and
it's it's really impossible to save if
this is a win or not
Bishop III is really a mistake iam
leading to exceptionally good counter
play Queen f5 is the stronger move and
there's some inner logic to that simply
keeping the pawn on the night on sorry
the bishop at d7 - to block the the
seventh rank and yeah white captured on
d7 and yeah what should I do now
it's it's useful to note that those
simple moves don't cut it White has got
three pieces here for the Queen and this
is not clear that this is winning black
probably should move the knight and
continue to attack the thing is where do
you go where do you go with the light
Kasparov played the move 93 and it turns
out that this was a mistake the MOOC
that was winning was Knight takes h3
this was winning in the game it still
intends this check and after check a8
king g7 rügen a7 here black has the good
and very important reply g5 using the
pawn as a shield here the pawn is
protected it can advance and black still
has an attack like this for example and
Quincy for this in fact wins for black
after let's say Knight takes e5 check
King g6 and 94 black has the counter
check with queen g4 and will win the
game like this
for example check and black hair black
wins this is some relatively easy to
believe the point is though what is
wrong with spur off smooth he played 93
the the problem is that Wyatt's Believe
It or Not could have drawn the Gambian
to which she didn't do
he played Bishop h6 but the rules that
really draws the game is rook check King
g7 and now Luke a7 and this is really a
clear-cut draw back then that took a
while to analyze this to make sure it is
really a draw
nowadays the computer instantly shows
zero zero zero but why is that
yeah White has a great counter-attack
and in fact it is black who needs to be
cautious in a way if you look at this
for example like grabs the bishop yeah
there's this discovered check and it's
really remarkable
what does black going to do now King
here check loses King here check check
check
also loses the Queen so you cannot go on
the sixth rank you need to go back this
is just not helping check so you need to
go to f8 and they get the check and what
now are you going to try to win okay go
on e7 I give this a check again how are
you going to try to win I give a check
again okay so you need to go here if you
want to try to win but again Jack
there's a check and what about this move
yeah the fun thing is
90-95 check and what now King here check
loses the Queen King to b7 when I give
this check and again King b6 it changes
the Queen and if black retreats check
checkmate you run into a checkmate or
checkmate also very nice black needs to
accept the draw
he cannot evacuate the king towards the
Queen side an amazing draw enter black
besides taking can look at other moves
but what what what other move is there
I mean if black tries this for example
there is a Ganges check and you cannot
go here because of this fork if you need
to go back again check I just sit those
checks again check remarkable check
check check
there are ways to lose check checkmate
it's very funny yeah it's it's great
white has a perpetual check I don't know
I don't know what what to say if it's a
mcaren I didn't find it maybe it would
have been a just outcome of the game
this is a fantastic draw but the coroner
played the move from after 93 played the
move Bishop h6 which is looking very
attractive threatens through KH and who
care fade and black needs to be a
precise iam the idea was 97 this is
focus power of plate okay check King f7
and now look h8 this was caution idea he
only had seconds on the clock here so
it's um it's a very understandable
yeah mistake to go for that it's very
tricky
what should like play now Ruka h7 is the
threat and let's say here this rook F a
check King on the seventh is Rakesh
seven what is black going to do he only
has really 1:1 convincing where this is
what Kasparov played look king of six
just going forward so after Luke at
eight
there's kingi five and the black king is
hiding within White's camp this is in
fact decisive there are there are no
worm no tricks anymore instead of rook
h8 but I mean they're all so what's the
move Knight e4 though sorry this is
still interesting in fact but black has
a defense here which is worth
remembering from just the general the
general concept of course you won't get
this exact position but note that here
blacks best defense white is threatening
the smooth ninety-five king of six Luke
evade for example or rook FHM
immediately white
that's the reckon with g5 year this is
the strongest defense it gives black
this additional square which is an
important defensive resource and in fact
the only move that really wins
convincingly after 94 this would have
been an alternative for white something
like check Luke f8 check here we need to
check it because it is an interesting
line rook h8 chance this this line
coming up check I'm showing you this
because of one one specific line if you
look at this position what display what
should black play the fun thing is the
the best move is King d8 if you go King
to seventh
White has a very strong move and this is
something check he would rook takes h7
with this point and what what's blacks
moves now he needs to retreat check and
in fact here check it's a draw again if
you try to win check you're going to
lose
check check and lose the Queen it's a
funny funny line again probably you had
the seducing already it's some very
complicated stuff but black black has a
winner of course here with King d8 but
the line is is funny there should be six
check clingy seven it's quite similar
but not yeah look at this black can take
it because data that in this some line
he has to move c4 and the C pawn will
promote it's a winning Knight endgame
white white can try to stop it with this
chatter is this move again so this is a
cheap one now coming so on it's a win
after all
94 would have been still really tricky
to to face but this wasn't played check
this was played and as mentioned
Kasparov found the only way to to
continue with King f6 yeah here coach
Choi basically together with when with
his flag falling he played King f3 and
check gave away the edge reborn and now
he lost some time basically at the same
at the same moment yeah he had no time
left at all white was lost now though
you can only check push the king forward
but you don't have any substantial
attack anymore so black is winning yeah
fantastic really fantastic better when
when Kasparov from beat corner in this
amazing fashion this was the most
spectacular game of this Olympiad and
probably the year and it was some very
important in this year for Kasparov
winning his first chess Oscar this is a
popular what what among chess players
that is some given out by the
chassé newspaper I think it's it's
called 64 this newspaper and this is
usually awarded to the best player of
the year voted by journalists and this
was the first time that Kasparov won it
and it wasn't so clear and this yet also
could have gone to cap off but this game
and Kasparov's performance at the
Olympiad really pushed the edge probably
towards him so that he was awarded this
prodigious prestigious award and also
this game really AM showed that Kasparov
would be the the next challenger
probably the most promising player and
that he will be the the favorite over
caution oi challenging Karpov again yeah
a fantastic battle it shows that the the
modern Benoni can be - absolutely
fascinating plate it's also shows that
it's razor sharp you need to be sharp as
a knife with your calculation and your
and your your technical tactical
awareness I hope you enjoyed this game
it is a very spectacular game very
entertaining to watch I hope you liked
it thanks for watching